hello there my name is Carlos Rena Solon
I'm the writer director of Colombia my
debut feature film about a poet returns
to New York City to rekindle an old
flame only to realize she's moved on it
is currently streaming online for as
little as $2.99 and today I want to
share five tips with you for making a no
budget movie
what's enough with the budget now it
varies a bit when you talk to filmmakers
in terms of the process do you consider
the budget or the story first me I like
to go with the budget because you can
build your story around it whatever
resources are available to you you can
use it to begin writing now our phone
kilometer came in a little under six
thousand dollars to get it in the can
but we didn't have the entire six
thousand dollars at our disposal when we
first started shooting that's something
that really hurt us and set us back from
shooting we have to pay actors on
lockdown locations but we couldn't do
that since we were shooting and paying
for everything as we worked our day jobs
and shut check the check it may seem
like an obvious thing to have all the
money up front but not so eager
filmmaker like me who is just so eager
to finish his first film
you've raised the money now it's time to
write the story what kind of story do
you write I suggest keeping it simple
well for comedy or a drama well for
horror thriller you might need more
money in time for continuity and special
effects but what for comedy or drama
your biggest worry is gonna be the
dialogue and the performances they said
as a director I'm much more manageable
for you are from Columbia relies heavily
on dialogue and what that allowed me to
do was make it like a hangout movie
where people have moments of
disappointment where they argue they
laugh or serious moments now one thing
you have to be careful of is the number
of characters you have in your story the
more you have the more of a concern it's
gonna be later when scheduling actors to
shoot Columbia has six characters and
that gave me a lot of trouble because
people work and have their personal
lives as well so I suggest having three
characters at the most biggest story
great examples of this would be movies
like Richard Linklater's tape and
Christopher Nolan's first movie
following
occasion location it's all about
location as the righteous story your
vision world will take place ideally you
want a location that is easily
accessible to you via your bedroom on
your parents house but if you don't have
those things you might have to pay for
kallenberg didn't get the bar so we
rented out a studio but the studio
presented us with a big issue sound the
studio was located in an industrial area
so there were a lot of trucks outside
loading and unloading so it was
definitely disruptive then down the hall
there was a big wedding rehearsal going
on you could imagine a nightmare that
that was my suggestion has always got
the location beforehand and if you're
running out of place make sure that ask
if your crew members will be the only
ones day on shoot day
this is a big one boom is a
collaborative medium and unless you're
jack-of-all-trades I can't do everything
yourself you're gonna need help whether
there's a sound recordist
cinematographer a sound mixer be careful
you trust with your film
I hired a sound mixer he took three
months to polish up the sound on kalam
brain which is ridiculous cause Kalama
is only 52 minutes long he'd miss
deadlines because of a personal issue
but then it would happen again and again
and he finally revealed liya taking on
another job just keeping really busy how
do you avoid this from happening before
you hire a sound mixer talk with their
references interview potential
candidates if possible give them
reasonably strict deadlines and also
make sure to tell them not to take on
any other jobs if they've taken on your
project especially if you've already
paid them
you finished your film that ready to
present it to the world what kind of
film festivals do you submit it to local
festivals international festivals one
thing is certain you've got to have a
plan of are your submissions I don't
submit to festivals that require more
than fifty dollars and even at fifty
dollars make sure that festival kiss
your kind of film you probably shouldn't
submit a comedy into a horror film
festival secondly seek out festivals
that are in their first second year
running these festivals may be a little
bit more receptive to no budget movies
than the bigger established film
festivals there are even festivals that
do online screenings which may be
beneficial to your film lastly keep in
mind these festivals require your
morning to run so be very selective in
your submission process and there you
have it now go make your film and
remember once you've made your film
normally can take that away from you my
name is Carlos Rena so check out my
uncle hombre streaming online piece
you